[Music]
hi folks I'm Jennifer sue the product
manager for job search and cloud
solution first I want to thank you
everyone for joining me this morning and
it looks like we have a full house so
it's really inspiring to see so many
people engaged in diversity and
inclusion so before we get started I
want to let folks know that this session
will be recorded and we'll share it
shortly after we'll also save some time
for Q&A at the end and just a quick
reminder if you have questions
throughout the session just go into the
Q&A link and there you can submit your
questions and we'll try to cover as many
as we can but we can we'll also follow
up after if we can't so today we'll talk
about how the definition of diversity is
evolving along with the applications of
machine learning when applied in the
talent space can be biased then I'll
share how we're helping businesses
transform recruiting with cloud town
solution and how we're helping to make
jobs on career sites more discoverable
and developing with inclusion as part of
the design and finally I'm excited to
have our customers here with us today
smash fly and Cox Enterprise will talk
about their own diversity and inclusion
efforts and their experience with cloud
town solution now let's get started
diversity and inclusion is starting to
gain momentum in the workplace 78% of
professionals and hiring managers said
that diversity is a top trend impacting
how they hire the nudge comes from
leadership where 69% of CEOs rank
diversity and inclusion as a top
business priority leading companies that
are working towards successfully towards
inclusion have also achieved tangible
financial benefits where gender diverse
executive teams are 21 percent more
likely to experience above average
profitability and
it's not just gender they had similar
findings with ethnic and cultural
diversity so it's not only the right
thing to do but it's also good for
business while there is still a lot of
work to be done in terms of demographic
representation the definition of
diversity is evolving expanding beyond
the traditional gender or ethnicity to
include the many other dimensions that
make us who we are such as our age
whether or not we are a caretaker or
perhaps a veteran and blend this with
cognitive diversity which includes our
personalities and our thinking styles
this is because the to work in tandem
cognitive diversity brings the mental
frameworks that people use to help solve
problems and demographic diversity taps
into that knowledge and elicit cognitive
diversity through its indirect effect on
personal behavior think about the last
time you had a great brainstorming
session with your team and how different
everyone was as a product manager my
favorite moments were seeing the
conversations between our oncologist who
studied gene therapy and a lead engineer
who worked on quantum computing or our
marketing lead who researched education
with a designer who was previously an
optometrist my team is also made up of
veterans millenials
- Gen X and Z and caretakers new ideas
come from my diverse way of thinking
when high-performing teams are both
demographically and cognitively diverse
there's a 20% increase in creativity and
in innovation
I'm sure you all have heard a lot about
the digital transformation these past
few days the key to the digital
transformation starts with a workforce
and having the right talent AI can help
transform businesses through recruiting
to help discover new jobs and a more
representative candidate pipeline but
the recruiting space is riddled with
complex and messy data
take for example nurses there are
hundreds of different nurse titles and
hundreds of different certifications and
that's because nurses also have
specialties within departments such as
the ICU that contains surgical pediatric
or neuro trauma nurses just to name a
few so when job descriptions are vague
such as nurse and doesn't include the
department or cases when it says or
equivalent experience the process is
time-consuming and frustrating similar
to how you can find a lot of software
engineering jobs but the details matter
between mobile iOS and Android or
programming languages such as Java or
Python for years
employers have used systems to help fill
job openings but the methods were often
crude a computer would identify keywords
on job descriptions then determine
whether or not those exact keywords are
present on a resume here are some of the
challenges in developing a model in
recruiting for a nurse on the resume is
a job title for an OBGYN and on the job
posting it's an LT RP nurse
there wasn't a match because the
keywords were not exactly the same even
though they're synonymous this is
because at some hospitals in ldrp nurse
stands for labor delivery recovery and
postpartum nurse which is similar to an
OBGYN nurse next it's difficult to track
all the possible accredited colleges the
various spellings and abbreviations and
what counts as or equivalent
and the same can be applied for licenses
lastly the job posting requires an
advanced cardiovascular life support
certification there was no match because
it's not listed on the resume but most
nurses and recruiters know that
employers provide this training for free
if you don't have it or need a refresher
and these are just a few examples where
there's room for improvement as you're
all aware it's important to think about
bias when using machine learning in
hiring the common issues stem from four
areas unclear use cases where there's
too much focus on the solution instead
of the problem so before digging into
the various models take a human centered
approach and establish a clear use case
first misaligned expectations where
there's a tendency to just throw
everything on a model and just let it
figure it out small data sets where
there isn't enough training data to
learn all the various patterns so make
sure you have a lot of relevant data and
bias data so spend time examining the
training data for bias
for the leaders in our audience these
are important considerations when
deciding on developing in-house or
evaluating technology providers now
let's go through how to apply these
methods and recruiting here's an example
of a nurse job search query based on the
data there's a need for identifying
12-hour shifts and narrowing location
radius to five miles but we only know
half the story of what they're looking
for and not why after speaking to users
we learned that the assumptions based on
just the data were misleading when
nurses look for jobs it's in terms of
shifts where longer shifts also implies
fewer days this nurse was actually
looking for a part-time job that's only
two days a week and not a 60 hour per
week job that pays overtime and a need
to commute by bike and not necessarily
within five miles by taking a human
centered approach and speaking to users
we can understand why and develop the
right solutions that addresses their
needs and then we can revisit and
understand if we're looking at the right
data now let's look at something more
complex where the use case is screening
a resume here the Job Description asked
for an RN with the bachelor's degree in
nursing and provides emotional care to
patients we reason that education
information would satisfy the education
requirement as for emotional care it
requires the ability to empathize and
communicate volunteer work is probably a
strong signal for empathy as for good
communication skills recent studies show
that multilingual people have better
communication skills
and you probably didn't need to know
that they're female so our hypothesis is
volunteer work and languages are
features that can predict the ability to
provide emotional care and by developing
a hypothesis it helps identify
reasonable features to begin with and
iterate on along with the ability to
detect if the necessary data is missing
not to mention it also aims towards a
less complex solution and this makes it
easier to debug and improve on the model
machine learning models require a lot of
relevant data how much is a lot that
depends on the problem but the more data
typically improves your model a good
rule of thumb is to have at least
thousands of examples for a basic linear
model and hundreds of thousands for a
neuro network for example in terms of
nursing jobs when these will need at
least thousands of labeled examples for
both the positive and negative cases so
this means thousands of nurses that can
provide emotional care and thousands
that can't and across all of the
different types of nurses so if there
are ten different types then we're
looking at at least twenty thousand
examples for a basic linear model and if
a neuro network is needed then the order
of magnitude is in the millions so if
you have less data consider finding a
partner that can bring the necessary
data scale needed now before we go into
examining the data if everyone in the
audience can imagine a shoe
now raise your hand if you imagine
sneakers okay high heels high tops
anyone high tops know given that
majority raise their hands to sneakers
we've immediately introduced a bias and
to add more complexity what color were
they
here are four types of bias something
that impacts all data collected is
reporting bias reporting bias occurs
when people annotate the frequency of
things that doesn't reflect the
real-world frequency but things that
they found interesting or worth noting
and this is so for this example for our
sneakers you may not know that sneakers
have rubber soles when relying on the
top tech frequency and this is because
rubber soles is ordinary and can go
without saying sampling bias where the
data source is not representative of all
the different variants for our shoes we
only had those that were typical to us
but we were missing Oxford's sandals or
rain boots latent bias when the model is
only shown a specific example so if the
historical data only contains sneakers
then it would be biased toward sneakers
and would not label high heels correctly
and interaction bias that occurs by the
way in which users interact with it so
in this room if everyone kept selecting
sneakers in a game then the model will
learn from the activity and be biased
towards sneakers and these are just a
few out of more than hundred types of
different human biases that may occur in
human machine learning data sets
so make sure to examine your data and
audit it for any human biases that may
skew your models predictions by using a
human centered approach you can
establish a clear use case by speaking
to users to focus on the problem and
then to develop a hypothesis to
determine what features and data are
necessary and make sure you have a lot
of data in recruiting it's hard to have
a lot of labeled data in hiring data
which is especially difficult across
every single occupation lastly examine
the data machine learning models will
reflect the data that they're trained on
so analyze your data carefully to ensure
you understand it and for our leaders in
the audience a lot of relevant data is
necessary so if you don't have enough
data consider finding a provider that
can bring the necessary data scale and
develop AI with care our team is using
AI to enhance and expand what's possible
in recruiting which is a critical
function of each and every growing
business now I'll go over what we've
built in cloud town solution to
transform the job search experience in
job search sometimes the results don't
match the job seekers intent in turn
that misunderstanding causes hours of
work to find the right job while others
give up and look somewhere else
this is a huge inefficiency that I'm
sure frustrates not just the job seeker
but businesses as well because
businesses spend a lot of effort to get
traffic on their sites but may lose the
candidates before they even see the job
here's an example of a job search for
nurse assistant which is someone who
supports and helps nurses there are a
hundred and fourteen results but it
turns out many of these jobs are not
even for the right role the top result
the top four results actually are for
nurses
and not the assistant the first job is
an administrative nurse the second is a
senior nurse that's an instructor and
the fourth result is a nurse
practitioner that requires a master's
degree in nursing to help solve these
problems we developed cloud count
solution cloud talent solution is a set
of api's and using machine learning to
better understand job content and job
seeker intent candidates get matched to
their ideal jobs faster and employers
attract and convert higher quality
candidates by showing more relevant
results at the core is a neural network
to understand jobs company skills in
education you can think of it as a
two-sided matching engine that takes in
the job seekers intent and employer job
openings and runs them through a set of
algorithms to determine if there's a
match or not it's all about
understanding the semantics around
people and the semantics around jobs and
using the power of machine learning to
make the best matches possible here's an
example of how cloud talent solution
understands a jobseekers query let's
start unpacking this part-time CNA waa
Australia part-time is an employment
type CNA is an acronym for the job title
certified nursing assistant this means
the person is looking for all job
content related to the occupation that
includes nurse aide and patient care
assistant
waa Australia is a region and acronym
for Western Australia this includes much
of the outback but also contains Perth
and all the way to Broome a port city in
the north all these signals are
important to consider when capturing a
job seekers career to understand the
intent and return all relevant jobs
underneath the hood of many of the
features and functionalities of cloud
town solutions its machine learning we
developed models specifically for the
recruiting domain from heuristic to
narrow networks that helps classify jobs
so that businesses can leverage facets
in their you
or semantics so that to match the
different languages that employers and
job seekers speak such as the ldrp
and the ob/gyn nurse here using
tensorflow we're able to visualize text
embeddings of job titles text embedding
Zarko occurrences of terms represented
in a vector words and phrases that
appear similar in context within
employment related data are trained to
be close in the embedding space the
resulting dense representation allow us
to train deep neural networks that takes
jobs as input for example individual is
a cluster of nurses where the different
nurse terms are close in proximity such
as the LPN which stands for a licensed
practical nurse and the school nurse and
terms that are further away such as the
medical technician are less similar my
team is actively working to improve
inclusion by taking a human centered
approach by using design and AI to
reduce repetitive tasks and free people
to focus on what humans do best
they build relationships and solve
problems for job search
this means we engage a diverse set of
jobseekers across different dimensions
such as occupations gender or career
stages from entry-level to those nearing
retirement this helps us understand the
different use case scenarios and build a
rich variety of user perspectives we're
also working on improving inclusion in
our model training procedures such as
detecting and measuring bias and
diversifying our data ultimately we
think AI will have the greatest impact
when everyone can access it and when
it's built with everyone's benefit in
mind
over the past few years our team has
spent time with hundreds of people to
understand their job search journey I
met a woman who was blind and as we were
searching for jobs across various sites
we came across a company that she was
interested in but we realized that the
job detail page was not accessible even
though the rest of the site was while I
could read the Job Description to her
she told me not to bother because the
career site is her first impression of a
career at that company and if that isn't
accessible then what would it be like on
a daily basis working there job search
is one of the first impressions a
candidate has with the business so it's
important to make jobs on your career
site more discoverable to a larger group
of candidates and make the experience
more inclusive now I'll go over a few
features we've developed to help
businesses reach more demographically
and cognitively diverse candidates each
year over a quarter of a million over
quarter of a million service members
transition from the US military to the
civilian world we've spoken to many
service members and it turns out the
language used to describe the military
service and civilian employment is not
always similar many transitioning
service members need a way to translate
their experience so that they don't miss
out on great opportunities and
businesses don't miss out on great
candidates we also learned that in the
US military occupational codes are used
to identify specific jobs to assist
servicemembers transitioning to the
civilian world we've added military
codes to our understanding of
occupations to surface the relevant
civilian jobs we're thrilled to have
recruit military in the audience today
hey Mike
they are a veteran recruiting company in
the u.s. that represents over a million
veterans since implementing cloud count
solution on their job board they've seen
record highs of almost twice as many
applications and we're proud to help
them with their mission to connect more
veteran to connect more transitioning
veterans to their first civilian job
another example is our global language
support in our service that leverages
the tight integration with Google
Translate neuro machine translations
back in the old days
traditional phrase based translation
systems perform their tasks by breaking
up sentences into multiple chunks and
then translate them phrase by phrase
this led to a disfluency in the
translation outputs and was not quite
like how we humans translate we read the
whole sentence understand its meaning
and then translate it neuro machine
translation mimics that here's an
example assist en today infer Mariya
certificado neuro machine translations
considers the entire input sentence as a
unit of translation so instead of
assistant nursing certified were able to
translate in return certified nursing
assistant jobs we also learned that
across the u.s. in major metropolitan
areas over a hundred different languages
are spoken at home and in Europe a large
portion of Europeans frequently search
online in their first language a few
weeks ago we announced an exciting new
feature for those who prefer to search
in their first language
we also returned the relevant jobs that
were posted in English so that these job
seekers don't miss out on jobs that they
would have otherwise missed
and finally commuting is one of the top
considerations for a job where 85% of us
professionals would take a pay cut for a
shorter commute hour commute search
feature surfaces jobs based on commute
time and transportation modes as you can
imagine to determine the shortest
commute time you'll have to identify all
the relevant different route options
between two points to answer queries
these permutations become costly as a
scale of the problem increases from one
metropolitan area to an entire country
or continent where 10,000 stops already
yields a hundred million pairs we
leveraged a tight integration with
Google Maps to gather this information
they're layering in our knowledge of
jobs where we've mapped millions of jobs
and developed the technology to answer
all of these commute time queries on the
fly as part of our research and speaking
to a broad base of users we learned that
some people need alternative commute
methods especially those living in
low-income communities or the nurse that
was searching for a job within biking
distance recently we announced a new
commute methods so that everyone can
find work no matter how they choose to
get there overall our clients are seeing
great results that include reduced
development time that saves them at
least an entire sprint each year on
their road map and double-digit gains in
their key performance metrics such as
applications and an increase in higher
quality candidates now let's hear
directly from customers about their
diversity goals experience with their
recent integration with cloud town
solution and how they're leveraging
inclusive features today we have Tom
Kenny the CEO of smash fly and Tom
brings over 20 years of leadership
experience in high-growth companies we
also have Adam Glassman the senior
manager of employment branding at Cox
Enterprise and has experience in
marketing branding
talent acquisition please welcome them
onto the stage thanks for joining us
today we're really excited about smash
flies recent integration with cloud
count solution and how we've been able
to showcase some of our inclusive
features on Cox Enterprises career site
Adam can you tell us a bit about
yourself and Cox enterprise and share
your perspective on the candidate
experience sure absolutely good morning
everybody
my name is Adam Glassman and as Jen
mentioned I lead the employment brand
and recruitment marketing team at Cox
Enterprises so who is Cox Enterprises
well we are one of the top privately
held companies in the country but also
one of the country's best kept secrets
we're a twenty billion dollar
organization whose three primary
business divisions include Cox
Communications Cox automotive and Cox
Media Group and under those divisions
there are brands that you know like auto
trader Kelly Blue Book and blue print RF
our technology and software teams are
really at the forefront of disrupting a
majority of these industries and it's
really a great time to be part of the
team simply because of that across the
globe were 60,000 employees strong all
focused on one primary thing and that's
to build a better future for the next
generation and we do that through a
number of different ways both for our
employees our communities our industries
and our planet - your second question
Jen about the candidate experience it
may actually come as a shock to those in
the room but most people find searching
for a job that's somewhat frustrating
and it can be a very difficult process
and they don't have recruiters hounding
them and stalking them online like I'm
sure most of you do for most members who
are looking for a new job the onus is
really on them to look for a new company
to find a match of both from a cultural
perspective a location perspective and a
brand perspective and to find that right
opportunity at the right time and so
they take a lot of time researching in
their own
number of different sites that they
visit to do that including a company
career site and so as they go through
their research phase in their process
that that experience can somewhat feel a
little clunky to them especially at the
point where they're ready to apply most
companies ask individuals to apply
online today and many of them don't even
apply don't even allow that application
to be mobile-friendly so there's another
point of contention for candidates if
you are actually applying on a desktop
the application can still feel very
clunky it feels outdated it's long and
laborious and so there is continued
frustration through that process once
you actually apply you tend to wait and
you wait some more and ultimately if
your background meets what the company
is looking for you hear back from a
recruiter and that starts you down the
path of potentially several rounds of
interviews which again can feel a little
laborious depending on the company I
will say across our industry there is a
renewed sense of focus on creating a
better candidate experience and so that
gives me some optimism for the future of
how we can improve that experience and I
think technology and AI can be avenues
for us to do that thanks Adam it's great
to be partnering with you and to help
improve the candidate experience Tom
could you share a bit about smash fly
and how AI can help transform recruiting
for your enterprise clients sure thanks
for having me this morning I apologize
for the glare a little bit for those of
you are saying the bright lights it is
actual baldness it's not fake so smash
fly is a company that was founded about
12 years ago and it was founded with the
purpose to really connect the right
talent with the right hiring managers at
the right time it's a very simple
prospect but when you think about the
complexity of how people look for jobs
how jobs are posted where jobs are
posted and with what Jen was showing
earlier all the different ways that
employers are using language and using
colors and styles to try to attract
talent there's no one single best way
and when smash fly really started to
take a look at this and the technology a
few years ago we recognized there was a
huge opportunity for us to leverage some
of the AI nml techniques to learn how
talent is engaging with employers but
then also how employers are engaging
with talent so when we think about it
smash flies in 69 countries around the
world where we have recruiters working
and we have talent that interface with
us and over 180 countries around the
world and if you think about the
microclimates of recruiting that that
represents
it's almost infinite and the number of
complications with the way people would
interface together the employers and the
talent so when we think about especially
the machine learning aspects there's
tons of data available and you ask any
data scientist or machine learning
person and they're gonna tell you the
two most important things that they need
are data lots of it but data that's good
you know Jen talked about the training
data sets and we looked at the training
data sets that we would have and the
value that it brought so we're
leveraging the AI and ML techniques to
really use that amount of volumous
information that we have 1.2 million
hires that we've done through the smash
flight platform and really move those
forward in a way that engages talent
engages them in a way that gets them
excited about an employer it's not just
about [ __ ] you don't just know [ __ ]
communication is your cable company you
know I was talking to Adam earlier and
he's got this whole automotive division
which was really crazy and then print
and web media radio media it's a huge
conglomerate organization well how does
smash fly help Cox with that it's like
we really try to move that emotive
action you know how do you create that
connection with the employer and there's
no way to do this in a human function
and we'd have hundreds of people look at
these job postings looking the way
people are tracking looking at reports
but they're not going to be doing a good
enough job for us because we need to be
moving faster we need to be looking in
places that we never thought to look
before so the AI and ml constructs
really what's going to move that forward
and if you think about it one of the
things that we're really trying to do
because it's that emotive response that
we want we're not trying to eliminate
the human we actually have a customer of
ours global company great company very
recognizable brand name they took a year
to
build a system that would use machine
learning deep learning neural networks
and they were going to create a process
by which they were gonna find the best
candidates that existed out there and
they put the system in place they spend
millions of dollars building it and six
months after they put it in place they
realized 50% fewer people were accepting
their job offers and the reason was
they'd eliminated the human element
completely so when we think about it
it's smash fly you know all the great
technology that's out there it's not
about replacing the human element it's
about augmenting what humans naturally
do what they do best so help the talent
find the human that's trying to hire
them and get to those outcomes much
faster thanks Tom we're excited to bring
AI with the human centered approach to
your clients talent acquisition process
now I'd love to hear from you both about
the importance of responsible AI and
inclusive hiring practices Tom would you
like to start with why this is important
to smash fly and to your customers
everything about bias in human resources
and in recruiting is one of the biggest
topics we have today how do you create
that inclusive environment how do you
create diversity and if anybody watched
the news this morning Gizmodo posted
something that Congress has introduced a
bill that will require companies that do
AI to document how it is eliminating
bias that's it's a pretty big step
because now we're recognizing the power
of AI and the power of machine learning
and now you've got people worried about
it and starting to regulate it whether
that's good or bad is indifferent but it
really raises the level of awareness
about how diversity inclusion and bias
works and systems you know there's a
great company out there Intel where
their CEO a few years ago said we want
to create a diverse workforce that
exceeds the standards across the board
you know if the standard in our industry
is 30% women engineers we want to do
that if the standard across the industry
is 50% african-american we want to do
that so not creating some pie-in-the-sky
numbers but creating something that says
the industry
this and we're not there and the Forbes
articles that you read about this are
just fascinating the CEO created a big
hairy audacious goal anybody's read
Cotter from Harvard knows the be hag is
a way to really inspire people and get
them to move to a goal and they set the
goal for 2020 but they achieved it long
before that and so when we think about
it working with Cox and working with
other customers that we have they want
the diverse and inclusive workforce 'as
they bring different skill sets you know
I don't know how many of you would think
that my first career was as an opera
singer you know I had a great time I
sang in seven different languages saying
in Europe saying in the US had a really
great time I had a tumor in my throat
and did my upper career technology was a
cool thing at the time in the 90s so I
thought what the heck I'll do that but
it's one of those things where I think
about things a little bit differently
than maybe a classically trained
engineer would and that just little bit
of diversity with me add some color to
the employee base and when we leverage
tools especially the Google search that
we put in place for Cox we're leveraging
a way that we're trying to create that
diverse in that inclusive environment in
ways that we don't want the humans just
to make that judgment call because even
if you make a judgment call about
diversity you're still using your
inherent bias to make that judgment call
so let's build systems and processes
that actually empower the human
engagement in a way that we develop
these inclusive relationships with
people a diverse workforce an inclusive
workforce is one that actually
transforms industries we see this
research everywhere and our ability to
provide that to our customers is one of
the most important things that we can do
at smash fly great thank you Tom we're
excited to share this vision with you
Adam if you can speak more on this topic
as an enterprise customer of the
technology what does in heart inclusive
hiring mean to Cox as a hiring company
and as a business sure so the important
thing to understand about Cox is that
diversity and inclusion are not
buzzwords it's not PR it's not publicity
it really is a core foundational value
within the company and it's been held
since it's very inception 120 years ago
and because it is a core
foundational value for us we act with
intention to try to make the workplace
as inclusive as possible and that takes
several different phases if you think
about the journey that somebody would
take at the very early point of
connecting with a brand and applying for
a position
it's that career sight experience as
well that Jen had talked about with
accessibility and making sure that their
search is connecting in the way that is
good for them it's the language we use
on our job descriptions it's the way a
recruiter evaluates talent and
recommends them to a hiring manager it's
the way a hiring manager evaluates
talent to ultimately make the offer for
someone to join the company it's the way
an employee experiences their work
within the company and so at Cox we have
steps along these different journey
paths to make sure that we are providing
the most inclusive area as possible we
know that as a business we want to have
those diverse ideas and those diverse
perspectives and those backgrounds
number one it's the right thing to do
but number two it does make our business
stronger from a from a cultural
perspective that is something that we
act with intention on and then we know
that employees when they feel warm and
welcomed in an organization and they can
feel comfortable in their own skin they
perform at a high level and they can do
amazing things at Cox we do have gender
diversity at the executive level which
I'm proud to say of our four divisions
we have chief human resource officers at
each of them and all four of them are
female across the board we've been
recognized by a number of different
diversity organizations for our efforts
including the Human Rights Campaign
Forbes diversity Inc among others great
Thank You Adam it's really inspiring to
hear about Cox's diversity inclusion
values now I'd like to hear from you
both about why you were excited about
our recent integration and the inclusive
features such as the veterans job search
the multilingual support and community
Tom would you like to start
so one of the biggest things for us when
we were looking at the Google search was
what do we buy and what do we build and
when we looked at our implementation it
was obvious to us that when you talk
about natural language processing you
talk about semantic analysis you talk
about just search in general I mean
Google's the world leader in that space
so when we thought about how do we
develop a better search capability for
these jobs it was a clear-cut answer for
us to partner with Google on this and
when you look at our base of customers
you know like I mentioned earlier 69
countries we have recruiters working in
the ability to leverage the
multi-language capabilities is huge for
us
and it's huge for our customers to be
able to say very very simply I need to
find a job with the language that I'm
most comfortable in maybe with a second
language shown to me that I'm also
comfortable in in multilingual societies
and be able to create that connection
very very quickly and when you think
about it even from the most simplest
things the user experience today with
most search systems you can say I want
to find an engineering job well if you
put in software engineer and it's a
basic boolean and/or construct you're
gonna end up with job postings with
product people and marketing people and
sales people because they're all gonna
say has to work well with engineers if
you're a technology company you're gonna
get all these jobs come up because it's
not smart enough to really understand it
and if you do it just by job title then
if you put engineer in that search
you're gonna miss all the jobs that are
listed as software developer so it's not
really gonna help you you know one of
the things that we saw with Google was
the ability to say well I'm looking for
an engineer position and you type it in
with Eng I and ER you misspelled it well
guess what you still get the the
relevant engineer positions that still
come up but one of the bigger things
that we saw you know it's near and dear
to my heart the military occupational
specialty codes and the ability to
search for that now I've been a
part-time military guy for 23 years now
I'm still an executive officer of an
airborne battalion in New Jersey and I
know how hard it is not just for people
that are transitioning from active duty
but people who are reservists who have
spent years trying to build up some
skills in the Army Reserve that they
don't know how to translate into the
civilian world
and a lot of these guys struggle
especially that since 2003 I was
deployed for about four and a half years
up to about 2014 and those are tough
deployments and those are tough things
to come home to and you don't always
know how to make that transition even if
you're a part-time person and you go
away for 15 months and you come back
your jobs gone or your wife's gone or
there's a challenge in your life and
you've got to find that next opportunity
well helping people translate that into
a real valuable job prospectus is hugely
important for the veterans community and
it was interesting last night we were
walking back from dinner he was walking
down the streets of San Francisco and I
was thinking about this inclusion and
diversity and what am I going to talk
about and it was interesting because I
noticed as I walked probably 10 15
percent of the folks that I saw on the
side of the street they're wearing a
jacket from the Gulf War in the 90s
they're wearing a jacket from the early
days of the wars in Iraq or Afghanistan
or a recent jacket because if you're a
military person you actually know the
different uniforms that have been issued
and you know by the uniform what time
period that uniform was designed for and
I had to think to myself you know we've
done 1.2 million jobs for people around
the world how many of those people that
are on the street are veterans and how
many of those people if we knew how to
reach them and we could give them the
capability to find that right next
opportunity how many of them would still
be on the street and how many of them
could we help lead really productive
lives and be a part of our society
because that's what diversity and
inclusion is all about it's about
finding the right opportunities for the
right people on the right companies and
giving them something to be proud about
every single day yeah I agree with
everything that you said Tom to
additional features that I know I've
been impressed with or the commute
search and the multi-language
capabilities so if you start with the
commute search one of my jobs in
employment brand is to tell a very real
authentic story of who we are as a
company and match that with what the
candidate is looking for so we're not
trying to oversell which
might actually tell a real story so that
the candidate is more informed and they
ultimately accept a job at a company
that they're looking for from a commute
perspective look let's be honest in the
majority of our city's traffic stinks
and so who wants to sit for two hours in
rush-hour traffic going back and forth
to a job most people are looking for a
very specific commute time and we can't
always change where our office locations
are and we don't always have remote work
and work from home opportunities so that
commute search is a very important
factor in what people are looking for in
a career and in a job because the worst
scenario for us is that somebody would
ultimately accept a job and they were
really looking for a 15-minute commute
but it turns out it's two hours and two
months down the road they're miserable
and they quit and that doesn't help
anybody it you have to start the process
all over again on both sides so that's
the worst case scenario for us and I
think the commute search is another one
of those features that will help improve
the experience and bring that
information right into the candidates
fingertips the second piece is the
multi-language capabilities and so Jen
talked a little bit about that earlier
but if we looked at five random
companies in the country and they had
the same five positions I bet you
dollars to doughnuts that they'd all
title them differently so five companies
with the same five jobs they'd all have
different titles on them and so that's
in the same language now imagine if you
don't speak that language natively we
know that translating isn't always
one-to-one the grammar is different the
syntax is different and so if you're
trying to search in your native language
which isn't necessarily the native
language that the company has posted in
good luck trying to find that job match
and so this is another one of those
features that puts the information at
the candidates fingertips to help
improve the experience so I'm excited
about both of those Adham Tom thank you
both for joining us today we're excited
to be working alongside with you to
connect more candidates with jobs please
give them a round of applause to adam
Khan thank you
[Applause]
so you've heard how a I can help with
inclusive hiring and how critical it is
to get this right for our customers now
I'll run through a few takeaways and
then we can get to your questions to
wrap up the definition of diversity is
evolving to be more inclusive and it's
not only the right thing to do but it's
also good for business
AI can transform recruiting but applying
AI to to recruiting has its risk and
needs to be handled with care by using a
human centered approach and speaking to
users you can establish a clear use case
and develop a hypothesis to determine
what features and data are necessary
then ensure you have a lot of relevant
data and examine that data if you are
considering recruitment technology
ensure your providers can bring the
necessary data scale and develop AI with
care cloud Town solution is transforming
recruiting with AI and inclusive
features and we're seeing positive
results lastly it's important to
remember as creators or influencers of
technology it's our responsibility to
develop with inclusion as part of the
design thank you
[Music]